[Musique]
francisin bonjour Merci de d'être à
nouveau avec nous on va parler d'Ere
autre partie de votre vie maintenant
celle qui concerne l'écriture et
apparemment elle est bien remplie c'est
vrai comment c'est venu cette envie
d'écrire déjà l'écriture c'est depuis
que je suis tout petit que j'ai commencé
à apprendre à écrire je crois que j'ai
j'ai vraiment aimé ça et puis j'ai été
un lecteur assidu parce que quand quand
j'ai on m'a appris à lire très tôt je
suis rentré à la maternelle je savais
déjà lire et écrire donc parce que ma
grand-mère m'avait déjà appris donc
voilà j'ai il paraît que j'ai j'étais
très curieux d'apprendre donc ouais ça
me plaisait voilà et puis après quand
j'ai commencé à lire c'était les débuts
du Livre de Poche donc je me suis comme
j'ai jamais trop dormi ah bon ouais non
non je d j'ai toujours dormi 4h30 5h par
nuit du temps voilà donc je je lisais je
disais c'était le début du livre de PO
de littérature et puis et j'écrivais
j'étais très très influencé par
Alexandre Duma donc enfin quand j'étais
au au
collège j'écrivais des des
romans
historiques inspirés par les trois
mousquetaires tout ça et mes camarades
me demandaient parce que c'était un
feuilleton il me demandaient la suite al
ah ou c'était formidable ça ah oui c'est
drôle et j'ai gardé encore là je je me
souviens j'ai encore les copies oui les
copies à carreaux ça s'appelait les les
diables à 4 ah et j'ai écrit ma première
pièce qui s'appelait les deux
barbouilleurs que j'ai joué en classe de
6e et qui a eu un gros succès ah mon
Dieu vous vraiment Pr précos alors voilà
et les profs alors ils adoraient oui ils
aimaient bien oui parce que parce que
j'avais une passion je pense que c'était
ça moi j'ai l'impression enfin c'est pas
une impression il y a il y a les livres
autobiographiques personnels et les
romans historiques dans votre
bibliographie ça ça a commencé en 2003
par un éditeur qui est venu me voir
enfin en disant mais tu racontes des
choses qui sont extraordinaire à les
rencontres que tu as fait enfin pourquoi
est-ce que tu crierais pas je dis
attends j'ai 50 et quelqu
voilà je veux pas que je non non ça sera
et puis j'ai et j'ai écrit alors ça ça a
pas mal marché puis premier c'était mon
Panton et descousus mon pantéon et
décousus voilà où je racontais donc mes
mes années de d'enfance jusqu'fance
jusqu'à 50 ans oui c'est ça jusqu'à 50
et quelques Ann ou d'acord ça ça a bien
marché bah oui et puis et puis j'ai eu
un on m'a dit tiens tu as une vraie
écriture tu as un style j'ai écrit mon
premier roman après qui qui s'appelait
degré de l'assitude toujours aux
éditions du Rocher d'accord qui é ouais
qui était un peu un règlement de compte
de pas historique non pas his non mais
qui était bien qu' a eu un un succès
très très honnête on dirait mais c'était
bien moi moi ça m'avait fait du bien
d'écrire ça et puis après un autre
éditeur une éditrice chez plomb et m'a
dit je voudrais déjeuner avec toi parce
que j'ai lu tuas tu as un style et tout
enfin qu'est-ce que tu veux écrire alors
je lui dit bah voilà j'ai peut-être des
idées je mais tu as rien d'autre je lu
dis si j'ai j'ai dans mes tiroirs une
pièce sur Molière que j'avais écrit on
revient à Molière en 6e ah bon ah non
non jeavais écré plus tout de même que
j'avais écrit vous ariez pu essayer de
la recaser celle non on sait jamais bon
en bref et donc là
elle me dit ben oui je je dois avoir 40
pages ben envoie-moi ça je lui envoie
elle
m'appelle le lendemain matin en me
disant mais je viens de lire ça mais
c'est ça qu'il faut que tu fasses fais
fais le Molière là que tu as envie de
faire le chef de troupe avec sa troupe
on l' enfin on a traité ENF toujours
l'auteur mais mais traite l'homme de
théâtre bon bon alors j'y vais et j'ai
et j'ai fait ça et ça a été un un succès
Molère chef de troupe voilà Molière chef
de troupe pour édition plomb et elle m'a
dit ben maintenant tu vas en faire un
tous les 2 ans et 2 ans après j'ai fait
donc tribouet donc le bouffon des rois
oui alors c'était quoi cette histoire
c'est l'histoire de Triboulet alors je
prends toujours des ENF des personnages
qui existé voord mais aès re triboul et
lui l'enfant terrible comment vous êtes
allé les chercher je vais chercher des
personnages qui sont des personnages un
petit peu hors du commun qui ont des
vies un petit peu h du commun alors moi
connu ou pas connu ou Triboulet oui
parce qu'il était le bouffon de de
François 1ierer et et Victor Hugo
l'avait traité dans dans sa pièce Le Roi
s'amuse et après verdit enfin bien sûr
dans dans Rigoletto et je me suis dit
tiens mais on n pas raconté l'histoire
elle me dit ah bah c'est intéressant
vas-y alors j'y vais et et je pars sur
parce que je connaissais bien la
Renaissance et François 1er et je
m'aperçois en commençant à écrire que
Triboulet avait été avant le bouffon de
Louis XI pendant 15 ans et Louis X
personne ne s'en souvient le père du
peuple le seur roi qui a baissé les
impôts c'est pour ça qu'on l'a oublié et
qui était marié à une femme formidable
qui était Anne de Bretagne et qui et
Triboulet était son bouffé son son que
bouffon pendant 15 ans et il a enchaîné
avec François 1er pendant 21 ans 36 ans
de extraordinaire très rare et j'ai
raconté ça d'accord et on remensant bien
sûr puisque c'est ou vous êtes documenté
vousmême vous faites vos recherches
vous-même je fais mes recherches
moi-même je c'est ça que j'aime bien
faire parce que je donc vous avez la
passion de l'histoire en même temps
voilàtoire je prends des fait
historiques qui sont absolument vrai et
puis après je fais vivre mes personnages
qui ont vraiment existé vous Remz le
voilà donc là ce ce Charles de de La
Bussière pareil Charlie hi poolite lare
est-ce qu'il y a un peu de vous dans
Charlie Hippolite on peut dire qu' il y
a toujours un peu de moi mais mais c'est
tout même est-ce que vous avez ce côté
rebelle assez loin non j'ai un côté moi
indépendant mais pas du tout rebelle non
non non je suis pas non non mais lui lui
c'est un il
estable il est ingérable absolument
voilà c'est Mme lui voilà moi je suis
plutôt ingérable mais mais mais mais
très sociable lui il était pas tellement
non il avait pas tell leement aimi
finalement alors ce qui était formidable
que j'ai vu ça ce comédien qui a
vraiment existé et qui et qui a traversé
les 15 années extraordinaires il est
passé de la de la prise de la Bastille à
la révolution donc à la à la convention
à la Constituante à la terreur ça permet
de tout réviser là d'un coup au
Directoire à l'Empire puisqu'il est mort
en 1808 il a côtoyé la montancier il a
côtoyé la
montancier voilà oui parce qu'il s'est
fait engager à un moment c'était un
farceur il né il a été même très loin
c'était des f lui a joué des tours hein
il a laissé des plumes he le pauvre oui
qui avait des même d'un goût douteux
mais mais il s'est mis en danger et et
on lui a dit il faut te protéger parce
que et là il s il a trouvé une place au
comité de Salut publfcher robes piierre
et che fou quitinville et là tous les
dossiers prs du danger des condamnés à
mort lui passaient entre les mains et là
il a commencé à faire disparaître des
pièces d'accusation qui permettraient de
ne pas envoyer personn voilà et il a
privilégié un petit peu bien sûr les
comédiens ceux qui lui étaient chers
Comé de la Comédie Française Joséphine
de boirnet même qui l'a sauvé la
montancier bien sûr et puis d'autres
Florient qui est le fabuliste enfin il a
sauvé plein de gens il pouvaiit pas
sauver
[Musique]
reste oui je sais écoutez c'est une très
belle histoire en tout cas moi je me
suis régalé bon un autre sujet beaucoup
moins rigolo mais néanmoins hyper
intéressant plein d'espoir ai plein
d'espoir oui et bah ci s'appelle Louis
paapa que vous avez écrit coécrit avec
votre épouse Gerson Perin absolument
voilà qui est un livre qui nous fait
découvrir un univers un monde qui n'est
malheureusement pas très connu du grand
public à savoir celui de l'autisme
puisque votre filsou Louis 11 ans 12 ans
il a 11 ans il a 11 ans
euh étiste ou connaî ce handicap et donc
vous nous
expliquer un peu votre votre combat
votre parcours et engagement oui je
crois que c'est ça oui c'est pas simple
B on explique ça c'est-à-dire que là
c'est c'est che un autre éditeur là
c'est che chez Jean lat ou et ils ont
proposé à ma femme d'écrire et puis ils
m'ont demandé est-ce que vous voudrez
pas va donner un témoignage aussi alors
j'ai dit non moi je veux pas écrire sur
sur Louis ça me mon engagement est vrai
auprès de de
l'association voilà ENF dont je suis le
parrain et don est membre actif et dont
et mon combat contre l'autisme
absolument il
existe existera toujours mais sûr
j'avais et puis on me dit mais mais je
dis est-ce que je peux réagir par
rapport à ce que dis remble voilà et là
m' dit ah c'est une très bne idée livre
à devoir fin et donc on a fait ce livre
voilà j'en suis pour donner l'espoir aux
gens parce qu'il y a un véritable espoir
pour pour montrer qu'on est aussi comme
tout le monde que que quand ça vous
tombe dessus c'est c'est énorme c'est un
la vie bascule la vie bascule et que et
qu'il y a que c'est important de rester
comme ça uni et que et que ce et qu'il
existe un traitement et que ce
traitement ABA donc l'analyse appliquée
du comportement qui est un traitement
qui a des résultats dans le monde entier
depuis plus de 40 ans qu'on avait
complètement ignoré en France a des
résultats puisque c'est un traitement
comportemental et qu'en France il y a
toujours les les traitements des
psychiatres et tout qui disent que c'est
voilà puis il y a eu cette ce bar
heureusement la la Haute Autorité de
Santé a reconnu les traitements
comportementaux depuis l'année dernière
il éit temps et ça avance un petit peu
enfin il y a il y a un tel chemin de
retard qu' fa qu' va falloir le combler
mais qui sera comblé en d'ici des
dizaines d'années mais déjà il y a il y
a un progrès il y a ça et puis Louis
surtout Louis qui a eu qui a eu la
chance de bénéficier de ce traitement et
que et qui a pu avoir des intervenant
dans le Nord justement pour bénéficier
de ce traitement c'est ça qui est
complètement fou c'est si si on n' pas
les moyens de s'exiler dans le Nord ou
en Belgique ah oui oui non mais c'est
c'est fou il y d'autre qui partent au
Canada il qui faut les moyen de faire ça
en Angleterre complèement ou oui c'est
c'est c'est complètement injuste et
c'est justement pour ça qu'on voudrait
qu'il y ait des familles qui n'ont pas
les moyens qui NT rien qui bénéf il
faudrait que que ça avance parce que
c'est un traitement qui coûte cher qui
coûte cher mais qui après avec les
progrès ne coûte plus rien mais voilà
bien sûr parce que Louis finalement il a
été traité en il y a pas de médicen hein
sulation ah bien sûr il a été traité
avec des intervenants pendant 3 ans et
et après à l'école puisqu'il a été à
l'école publique suivi bien sûr que
toujours par un intervenant donc qui
l'accompagnait mais qui mais qui de plus
en plus ne prenait pas voilà le laisser
libre parce que maintenant maintenant il
est autonome à la maison on a plus
d'intervenant ni à la maison ni à
l'école ni à l'école maintenant
maintenant mon épouse fait l'école à la
maison parce que c'est RA on a trouvé ça
pour des raisons plus plus pratique
puisque je tourne beaucoup en province
et tout donc c'est plus pratique
d'emmener les enfants voilà mais
autrement il n'a plus besoin
d'intervenant il est il est comme ses
frères et sœurs parce qu'il a de après
on a eu deux autres enfant en qui vont
très très bien eux qui on voilà et et
donc il est autonome et donc ça ça c'est
un c'est un soulagement que pour lui
surtout et pour nous aussi bien sûr
parce que et ce qui est donc hallucinant
c'est ce manque d'information des
médecins je je parle juste vite fait du
de la pédiatre qui a dit pendant des
années à votre épouse vous inquiétez pas
ça va ça va très bien c'est complètement
dingue quand même oui il y a il y a une
désinformation pour tous les gens il
faut une formation à refaire oui déjà là
maintenant il y a un Diagnos un
diagnosti 18 Mo voilà ça c'est
formidable on le demande depuis
longtemps oui je m'en doute avant
fallait attendre 3 ans on perdait 3 ans
parce qu'en fait plus les comportements
euh sont pris en main et changer tôau et
plus c'est facile à à faire évoluer dans
le exactement à progresserfin pour les
progrès donc donc il y a pas de remède
miracle c'est pas un remè miracle c'est
simplement ça marche donc donc il
faut il faut qu'il soit pris en compte
en même temps que d'autres traitements
voilà c'est tout ce dit bon ben
écoutez soyons entendus B j'espère et
puis je recommande ce livre
effectivement bah à tous ceux que ça
intéresse et notamment aux enseignants
qui manqu souvent d'information
malheureusement sur ce handicap oui bien
sûr c'est pas de leur faute c'est pas de
leur faute mais voilà ils peuvent lire
le livre merci Francis Perin c'était
passionnant et à très vite j'espère
j'espère votre
[Musique]
santé
I